october could potentially be the most
dangerous month of 2020
and here's why i think at this point
again we all know that this has been a
very weird year from pandemic you know
coronavirus kova china
won you know shutting down unemployed 55
million wanting to get checked stimulus
blm george freud nba show i mean i can
go
on and on and on and on and on
all of this is happening during election
year
so why could october be the worst month
of the year because it's a month before
election now remember this is all
speculation i don't have the data
i don't have the insider information
people send me some random emails
saying protesting is going to be the
ugliest it's ever been in the month of
october
but that's a lot of speculation no one's
given a base on any specific data
there's going to be militia there's
going to be this i'm not trying to scare
you this is all i'm saying
my style of doing business and doing
life
is anticipation and anticipation doesn't
mean a hundred percent of crisis is
going to take place
anticipation simply means you prepare in
case
a crisis takes place but let's you and i
say we have a book the newspaper
on october 20th of 2020 and we can read
the news and find out exactly what
happens
every single day the month the month of
october 20. and we know
it's going to be the most dangerous
month of the year protesting division
divisiveness biden trump
pence kamala democrats republicans media
hash
going crazy one side doesn't want to see
biden president one side doesn't want us
to try and become president
and they're going nuts how wild you
think it's going to be it's going to be
pretty intense
let's say it's going to get ugly how are
you going to protect yourself and is
there an opportunity
there for you it's a couple ways i want
you to look at it number one
let's look at it from ourselves from you
how can you protect you
everything with protection has to be to
follow number one
if you got a family you got to make sure
you protect yourself meaning
your kids cannot go play by themselves
without an adult
number two if you got a baby
two-year-old
never have an adult go to a park with
your two-year-old or four-year-old
just in case you never know it's just
protecting yourself always have two
adults going not one
you got two kids going with one adult
these two kids are four years old five
years old six years old
in the park playing with one adult you
need two adults some happens you got
protection
because there's two to catch them right
if something were to take place another
one
maybe it's time for you to get some kind
of protection for your house i don't
know go buy a gun
go buy something for you to feel
protected and probably the month of
september once you get your license
go to a range and take your wife and
husband and go shoot a little bit and
get a feel for it
just to protect your family and your
household i remember one time when my
car got broken into
right in front of my house and i had a
newborn baby and we were living in
northridge california off of encino
boulevard
in a nice-looking house it was supposed
to be a nice community
it was a range rover they broke into
they took everything out of it i bought
a gun the next day and i moved into a
gated community the next month like this
because i work in
anticipation what else can you do if you
run a business
maybe you can get some kind of an
insurance to protect your business maybe
you can get security
for the month of october even if it's
four weeks even if it costs you a
hundred bucks a day
just to get security there at a time
that's maybe later maybe it's 50 bucks a
day
you hire somebody to be there for your
security you could do those things to
protect yourself right
those are things you can do and on top
of that i probably wouldn't be making
any kind of major
purchases right now i'd be staying
liquid i'd be staying cash
i'm not going nuts this again is in case
that takes place
now let me give you the other side if
i'm explaining to you this that october
could be
a random weird month and let's say it
does end up becoming a random weird
month
how can your business or whatever you do
professionally
help me as a customer so think about
that what do you do
if it's insurance talking about your
insurance product if it's real estate
talking about getting some kind of
protection for myself if it's
anything to do that you can make my life
better in the month of october
go speak to your customers about it and
again it's not factual
it's not a hundred percent all of this
is just like a hedge fund or an investor
or
money manager assistant looks at all the
different trends and says let me see
where is gold going to be going my name
is warren buffett let's go out there and
buy
gold or 561 million dollars in gold and
let me go buy some apple stock at 40
billion dollars
and it goes to 122 billion or if i'm
warren buffett
why don't we have 147 billion dollars in
cash at berkshire hathaway
why because he probably is studying the
trends that he's seen the last 60 years
and he's thinking there's going to be
some opportunities come along the next
six months
that he's staying cash why is he doing
that it's all anticipation
he's not someone that's nostradamus he
can't predict the future it's purely
odds
and i'm simply saying i don't want you
to go around saying pat saying october
is going to be
end of the world i'm just speculating
remember
i'm speculating and off of speculation
i'm preparing
and challenging you to anticipate if
something were to happen
how could you protect yourself and your
family and how could you protect
your clients and those who are looking
to take advantage of services you offer
so having said that
i don't want you to get scared i don't
want you to panic i don't want you to
biting your nails oh my gosh i don't
know what's up
i said this why don't you go watch this
video and it talks about wartime
leadership during chronovirus
if you've not watched it you also have
to realize all this wealth that's being
made during coronavirus
is because some people are treating
themselves as a leader as a wartime
leader
and people want to follow them so if you
do that watch this video then go watch
this video you make the right moves
people are going to follow you as well
having said that have a wonderful week
this week
[Music]